so are these these tools are these new
mathematical objects going to be able to
help us work out what on earth is
happening here I need a bit more space
but I'll leave that that quadratic
minute what you have a quadratic and you
can't make me factorize right what do
you do with that kind of thing
clearly you use the quadratic formula
right the quadratic formula a quadratic
formula helps you work out okay given a
B and C what are the solutions to this
okay now you might remember the
quadratic formula it actually comes from
completing the square we don't usually
like completing a square very much but
it's useful in fact it's what I use to
rewrite rewrite this as this do you
remember this equals zero okay
now if I rewrite it like this you can
see all I need to do is rearrange this a
little bit and make X the subject and
the solution will jump out of us right
so here I'm going to say okay I've got X
plus 1 all squared equals negative 3 now
just like yeah instead of saying oh I
have a negative number on the right hand
side I can't take square roots I'm just
going to say that's okay I'm gonna let
us not just break the rules just make
some new rules right I'm gonna take the
square roots of both sides that leaves
me with X plus 1 on this side and pass
or minus the square root of negative 3
on this side but I can rewrite the
square root of negative 3 as root 3 by
right I've already established this so
I'm gonna do two things here number one
I'm gonna keep this one over the other
side so I'll subtract one from both
sides that gives me negative one and
then I'm gonna rewrite this guy here as
root three I'm occasions
so minus root three by so in other words
I now have an alpha and a bigger like
this is one line but it's actually got
two values in there hiding right what
this means is that alpha is one of them
and Beyond is the other one okay now
look does this make sense of what we've
seen before
we said that the sum of the roots was
negative two now the product of the
roots is four or look at the Sun clearly
the Sun works doesn't it because if you
add alpha and read it together
these guys over here write this
imaginary bit well there's a negative
imaginary a positive imaginary bit and
when you add they just cancel each other
out okay that's just these you read the
negative ones and got two of them what's
so negative two now the product takes a
little more work you can't just look at
it say oh obviously right so that's okay
I'm just going to multiply now that I
know what these words are I'm just going
to multiply them together I can write
them like this okay now I can do this in
one of two ways I could just like bash
out this of the algebra here and I can
just say okay this term times these guys
and then expand and then I'll say this
term times these guys and then spend but
you'll notice that this will work
anywhere anywhere but these two numbers
are special right they're not just a
random pair of numbers that I have to
expand out they're related to each other
right alpha a beta the same thing minus
the same thing plus these are what we
call well when you have SERDES right
like if you saw 3 plus root 5 and 3
minus root 5 you call these guys
conjugates right and it's kind of what
you have over here but these aren't your
grandma house code you guys right these
have complex bits in them so we call
these 9
this is what writing down complex
conjugates they're complex because
there's this imaginary thing flying
around over here but they're still
conjugates in the way that these guys
are conjugates and we can take advantage
of what conjugates do this is a minus B
times a plus B right
a much PA plus B 1 is 2 units students
we know what to do with this this is
difference of squares
okay now look at it with me if it's
difference of squares a minus B a plus B
what's a the a is just this first number
you write negative 1 so a squared and
then I'm gonna take away B Square now
let's be it's gonna be root 3 by 3 all
right a squared minus B squared right
what's gonna happen here I know what to
do in this one that's just 1 this is a
bit weird up but I can still deal with
it if I just take this bit square that
take this bit square that okay it's just
starting to take some shape now okay
this is one takeaway root 3 Times root 3
is 3
I swear well the very way I defined I
back in the beginning is this the square
root of negative 1 right so if you
square the square root under 1 you
better get negative 1 right so this is 3
times negative 1 that's 1 plus 3 which
surprise surprise he's full okay so it's
awesome and it starts up weed and it's
like fun these things is strange but it
makes perfect sense of something we've
already observed you know it's not that
these rezoning system the the sunup
random of meaningless the roots do exist
and the southern product just happened
to cancel out those imaginary parts they
just leave you with something real